with the first pick in the 2018 NBA
Draft the Phoenix Suns select DeAndre
[Applause]
[Music]
spin works inside [ __ ] at the [ __ ] it
already got a double-double
understanding of the game of basketball
[Music]
[Applause]
as eight over the top and quickly slams
it down
[Applause]
Nathan dismiss mansion on the smaller
not hard to spend
in this land
[Music]
be back to earth in the three-point
shooting category is AP up top and drops
it in the three
Valanciunas blocking shots can't get if
any thunderous follow slam of the Andre
[Music]
[Applause]
on the place stay right there
[Music]
sit down long is what gets inside hangs
on the iron feet and inside them Dave is
coming over to help out there
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the control
Haitian isn't working over in the market
[Music]
and then what they teach in over the top
upper top the disconnect on the past
but the tremendous bounce take any rest
wraps himself all the time - do I look
like a baton